Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 20. And we're going to move on from
the idea generation process now. We're
going to move on to the second stage,
which is extremely crucial, called
gatekeeping.
Now, gatekeeping is a process that is
essentially used as a barrier between your
ideas and your real capital. It's you
putting up a barrier to try and stop
yourself doing silly things, as in, taking
an idea and just putting the idea on
straight away.
So, let's run through this quickly again.
This concept that your ideas at this stage
are just ideas. They're not trades. A good
idea might end up being a bad trade. And a
bad idea will usually just end up becoming
a bad trade.
So, when we go, when we have a look at
this, let's, let's think of the example
where we think we've got a really, really
good idea. And we buy a stock or an asset
at 100.
And we decide that if it trades at 90,
we're just going to trade out. So, it goes
from 100 to 90 and we trade out. We just
put the idea on straight away. And it just
goes to 90 almost immediately, within
days.
So, we end up being forced to trade out.
We essentially get stopped out. The trade
hits our stock loss.
But then, that asset goes from 90 to 400.
What you've actually just done there as a
trader is the worst thing you can possibly
do, which is you had a good idea.
You put it on straight away. You put it on
straight away. You mistimed it. And you
were proved to be right, but you actually
lost money.
That's why we have the barrier of
gatekeeping to stop us mistiming good
trades.
But it's also to stop us entering bad
trades. So, imagine you buy this asset at
100. It trades at 90. And you trade out.
And then, this asset just goes to zero.
Well, that's all fine that you overlaid
some risk management onto it by stopping
yourself out at 90.
But you could have actually saved yourself
10 by just having a gatekeeping process in
place, so you didn't actually enter the
trade at all.
We're looking here at somebody generating
an idea and just putting the trade on
straight away.
This is why we have a gatekeeping process.
And the gatekeeping process is essentially
two things.
Technical analysis. So, using technical
analysis to better time your trades and to
stop yourself entering bad trades.
And price action indicators. And the price
action indicator we're going to look at
here the most is the watch list.
And the processes you use in your watch
list to make sure that you enter good
trades in well-timed scenarios and you try
not to enter bad trades.
So, whatever ends up in your portfolio
stands an extremely high probability of
making money.
Now, up to this stage, what we've done is
we've generated an idea or multiple ideas
through the world view.
And the world view has given us a view on
the stock market, commodities, currencies
and rates.
And within the stock market, we've drilled
down.
We've gone from the index level through
the sector level to the stock level and
we've drilled from the top down and
combined that with some bottom-up analysis
on PE.
Now, we're moving on to gatekeeping, which
essentially is our idea cleansing phase.
Is the idea correct in terms of timing?
You might be early.
You might be late.
It might be original.
It might be unoriginal.
The point here is to stop yourself putting
mistiming good trades and putting bad
trades on altogether.
Now, a lot of retail traders consider
themselves useful and knowledgeable at
technical analysis.
That's all fine.
You can put whatever technical analysis
you want to put into this process.
But the main point here is that we're
looking at two things in terms of TA.
Firstly, it comes in at the gatekeeping
stage.
It doesn't generate ideas for you.
That's the first mistake that retail
traders always make.
It's very, very easy to think that just
watching a line on a chart will give you
an idea when, in fact, the line is just
following the price anyway.
The most important indicator is the price
itself.
Secondly, it's the misinterpretation of
technical analysis or misinterpretation of
a chart when you pull it up.
So, there's many, many scenarios that
we're going to go through in the
presentation where, when you look at
certain things in a chart, retail traders
often misinterpret what they're seeing.
And that means it becomes unuseful rather
than useful as a tool.
So, let's go to the presentation.
Let's take the first step in gatekeeping
and look at technical analysis.
And I'll see you at the end of video 20
with a summary of technical analysis TA.
Okay, so let's move on to the stage of
gatekeeping.
So, let's assume now that you've got tons
and tons and tons of ideas.
You've got a world view.
You've got ideas in commodities,
currencies, rates.
You've got ideas in sectors, stocks.
What do you do next?
Obviously, everybody thinks their ideas
are brilliant.
No one shortlists a bunch of ideas because
they're all rubbish.
Everybody thinks their ideas are great.
So, what do you do next?
You've got to put a barrier between
yourself and your capital.
Your ideas and your capital.
The idea of putting a barrier between your
ideas and your real money is to stop
yourself doing something stupid.
What was the most annoying thing of being
a trader that we discussed yesterday?
When you're right and you lose money.
So, you buy a stock at 100 because you
think it's a great idea.
You get stopped out at 92 and then it goes
to 400.
If you have processes that put a barrier
between your ideas and your capital,
you're less likely to do stupid things.
So, what we're trying to do is go through
these processes to time things in the best
way possible.
So, when things end up in our portfolio,
at least we've done the work.
And if we're wrong, we're just wrong.
It's better to be wrong and lose money
than lose money and be right.
Does that make sense?
So, what do we do?
We apply a screening process of technical
analysis, TA, and price action indicators.
If all the planets are aligned and all
those boxes are ticked,
then we can seriously consider committing
capital to this idea, to an idea.
So, this is what we're going to cover now.
Technical analysis in this part of the
process.
And TA is just one part of the gatekeeping
process to stop yourself doing something
stupid.
First, don't confuse technical analysis
with a tool that generates ideas.
Retail traders are doing it in totally the
reverse.
All the processes are now in reverse.
So, what professional traders do.
So, professional traders will start at the
top and work their way down,
then pull up the chart to see if the chart
agrees with what they think.
So, your fundamentals come first.
Your world view, your industry view, your
sector view.
Your stock view, you pull up the chart.
Not pull up the chart, take a position.
When it goes wrong, then work out why.
Then justify it.
Then get a world view.
And then put it in your pension.
And it goes to zero.
That's the reverse order of doing things.
So, don't confuse TA with a tool that
starts and generates you ideas.
The vast majority of technical analysis
indicators react to the price.
They follow the price.
The price itself is the indicator that's
important.
So, it doesn't give you trade ideas.
What it does is it gives you a pictorial
representation of what's happened in the
past.
I might give you some clues as to when you
can time your entry to the trade.
It's not useless.
It's quite useful.
And we'll go through some of the TA stuff
that you can look at to time positions a
bit better.
Try to think of it as a traffic light
system.
Where you've got your fundamental view on
something.
Where you think the world's going to go
up, for example.
You think a sector's going to go up.
You think a stock's going to go up.
Then you pull up the chart.
And the chart literally says, there's no
way you should be buying this at the
moment.
It's a red in the traffic light system.
Just stick it on your watch list.
When the technicals move in your favour.
Then the timing is better.
If you pull up the chart.
And technically everything agrees with
what you're thinking.
And it looks like a great entry point.
Don't be afraid to commit some capital to
it.
It means it's a decent idea.
If it's amber.
You could just be too early.
Same as red.
It can go on the watch list.
Or you might take a starter position.
What we call a half position.
A starter position.
Where you say, well my ideal size in this
situation.
Is to maybe buy £10,000 worth.
But at the moment the technicals are
neither here nor there.
So I'm going to buy £5,000.
And just see what happens.
And put quite a wide stop loss on the
trade.
Give myself a chance of making money.
The contribution of that position to the
rest of your portfolio.
Your portfolio should not hurt you.
In the short term.
Big mistakes of TA.
First one we've covered.
Getting a trade idea from a chart.
It's totally amateur.
Going short of an asset that you're
fundamentally bullish on because the
technicals are bearish.
So you pull up the chart and the
technicals look like the stock is going
down.
But everything you've done up to this
point says that stock a year from now will
be higher.
And you get convinced by the chart to
short it.
And then it goes through the roof.
Vice versa.
Going long an asset that you're
fundamentally bearish on.
You pull up the chart.
It looks like technically everything's
great.
And it looks like it's going to go up
forever.
All the work to that point you've done is
bearish.
And you get convinced by the chart to buy
some.
And then it halves.
Again, no worse feeling in the world to
know the real situation, be right and use
money.
This happens time and time again.
Even in the professional world.
That's the type of stuff you get fired
for.
Where you walk into an office and ask for
an increase in capital because you've done
loads of work on the situation.
And you're fundamentally bullish on it.
And then the chart sucks you in to be
short.
And then you end up losing money.
You'll get fired for it.
So before you pull up your charts, you're
going to have fundamental predispositions.
Now this is where you have to be careful.
Because when you're fundamentally bullish
on something and the technicals aren't
quite there.
Or fundamentally bearish on something and
the technicals aren't quite there.
You're better not to participate at the
moment.
But when you've got fundamental
predispositions, it's very difficult to
control those emotions to stop yourself
doing stupid things.
You have to just stick it on the watch
list and wait.
And be patient.
Nothing wrong with being patient.
You can end up buying a stock higher than
where it was when you first started
looking at it.
But the technicals are all in your favour.
The risk reward on that trade is now
better.
So in terms of technicals, you can get as
complicated as you want.
If you feel the need to get complicated on
technicals, and you know much more than me
about TA, which some of you probably will.
Feel free to add it into this section.
But see it for what it is.
It's a chart.
And the chart follows the price.
All the technical indicators follow the
price.
The price is the most important.
So you can add any amount of technicals
into this point.
Anywhere you want.
That's fine.
But make sure when you're looking at TA,
you treat it for what it is and put it in
the process at the right, where it
belongs.
Don't work backwards.
Start with technicals and then find out
fundamental reasons why you should be
doing something.
Because the chart is telling you to do
something.
So often technicals will tell you as much
as what not to do as to what to do.
So given your fundamental predisposition
of being bearish, do you short the stock
when you see this?
No, you wait for it to break.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bullish, this confirms what you think.
So you're now looking for entry around
trend, if you can get it.
Trending stocks downwards.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bullish, do you buy this?
No.
Stick it on the watch list.
Wait for it to break up to the upside.
Wait for it to break the trend.
So what if it breaks in a month's time?
Then the risk-reward on the trade is
probably better than it was before.
But do you have to make a new fundamental
analysis of what you did a month ago?
Yeah, you'll look at it again to see if
anything's changed.
Is it worth buying at the bottom of the
channel?
Would that still be a valid entry?
Well, who says it's the bottom of the
channel at that point?
I mean, if I see a channel like this
and...
No, you're fighting the trend.
You're fighting the trend because the
overall trend is down.
If you've got a bullish fundamental
predisposition and this is the chart you
pull up,
you're better off waiting.
Just stick it on the watch list.
What you're going to look at in the
context of all the opportunities in the
world, yeah?
40,000 stocks in the world, 40,000 assets
in the world, sorry,
equals 40,000 opportunities
and actually 40,000 to the power of 39,999
opportunities
because you have lots of spread rates.
So there's literally a limitless amount of
opportunities in the world.
If your fundamental predisposition on this
is bullish,
just time it better.
Try and time it better by waiting for the
price to confirm what you're thinking.
You see, we're trying to predict what's
going to happen in 6, 12 months' time.
When you start seeing it slowly happening,
that's when you become convinced that it's
actually getting to be a correct
situation, yeah?
What about ranging stocks or ranging
assets?
If you've got a fundamental predisposition
that's bullish,
what do you do in this situation?
Huh?
Half position.
Half position?
So would you say this is an amber on the
traffic lights?
Who says it's an amber?
Who says it's a red?
It's a red because it hasn't broken from
the channel yet.
Who says it's a green?
You just go in full position.
It's a bit subjective.
It's a bit subjective, ranging stocks.
It's somewhere between watch list and a
half position.
Why?
Well, all that is telling me is that
someone in the market thinks that it's
cheap at 6.
That's why they're buying it.
And someone in the market thinks it's
expensive at 8.
That's why they're selling it.
But there's no such thing as cheap and
expensive.
So you might wait for it to break out
before you commit or you might commit a
little bit.
It doesn't really matter.
What that's telling you is that the
market's a bit screwed up at the moment.
Does that make sense?
Why is it screwed up?
Because we know that there's no such thing
as cheap and expensive.
That stock in 12 months' time could be at
$40.
And that range is totally irrelevant.
You'll see this time and time again in the
markets.
Head and shoulders formations where you've
got a left shoulder, a head, and a right
shoulder.
What's actually happening in the price?
Well, you've seen a bullish trend in the
past and you've had a blow off top.
And now the price momentum is slowing
down.
And at this point here, it's broken what's
called the neckline.
And in technical analysis, what you would
expect is a move to the downside that's
around the size of the head from the
neckline.
So the head from the neckline, $8 to $11.
So a drop of $3.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bullish and you see this, and you're here,
do you buy?
No.
Stick it on the watch list.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bearish and it's broken the neckline,
what do you do?
That's a bright green light.
Go in big.
And put your stop loss above the neckline.
What about reverse head and shoulders?
Your fundamental predisposition is
bearish.
And you see this.
Red, amber, or green?
Red.
Very bright red.
It's going up $3.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bullish, green.
So again, it tells you as much what not to
do as what to do.
When stocks put in double tops and double
bottoms.
And then you see a break through a double
top and you see a break through previous
support.
It's exactly the same way as everything
we've looked at already.
Fundamental predisposition of bullish,
stick it on the watch list and wait.
You might be right 12 months from now.
The stock could be $30 in 12 months.
But at the moment, the timing is poor.
You want to see that stabilize and break
in some way back before you take a
position.
What about a double bottom with a break
down?
A false breakout, we call it.
Fundamental predisposition of bullish.
What do you do?
With a false breakout.
Neither here nor there.
It's an amber.
Stick it on the watch list.
If it goes a bit lower, maybe you might
buy some around support.
Fundamental predisposition of bearish.
It's amber or red.
Just let it break support and short it.
You want momentum behind your idea.
You'll see a lot of these bullish flags.
Where basically buyers have stepped into
the market.
And now they're trying to get cheaper
prices.
But they're still there.
And then it breaks the channel to the
outside.
It's a flag formation.
A bullish flag.
What not to do.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bearish.
Short on a flag breakout.
Fundamental predisposition is bullish.
Buy on a flag breakout.
What about a pennant formation?
A pennant formation is just exactly the
same.
As a flag.
But converges in a triangle.
Instead of a channel.
Fundamental predisposition is bearish
here.
Don't do anything.
Stick it on the watch list.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bullish.
Get involved.
Don't be afraid.
Totally the opposite.
Bearish flag.
Opposite of bullish flag.
Sellers have stepped into the market.
They're trying to sell.
For higher prices.
But then eventually.
They have to accept lower prices.
If your fundamental predisposition is
bullish.
The momentum here is down.
Do nothing.
Stick it on the watch list.
Your fundamental predisposition is
bearish.
Jump all over it.
Same with a bearish pennant.
What about with volume?
When you look at volume.
So it's the same again.
Large moves.
In assets.
Combined with big amounts of volume.
Or higher than normal amounts of volume.
If you're bullish in this situation.
And you're seeing.
Big volume.
In this move.
As in the highest volume it's been for a
year.
And you're bullish.
You're better off waiting.
You need that to stabilize.
Before you actually commit.
So instead of buying it here.
On huge volume.
And being stopped out.
Here.
You buy it for the same price here.
When you've got the momentum to the
upside.
When there's low volume.
What if you're bearish?
It's a great signal if you're bearish.
Get short.
Relative strength index.
Who knows about this?
So the average of the previous.
Market convention is 14 days.
The average of the up closing prices.
And the average of 14 days down closing
prices.
Indexed.
So standard RSI measures will tell you
that.
If it goes over an index level of 70.
It's overbought.
If it goes under an index level of 30.
It's oversold.
But that's.
Completely the wrong way to look at it.
Because the stock.
Can be above 70.
Or even 80.
Or even 90.
On the index.
And just go sideways.
In price.
And then the index can go down to 50.
So the price might never come down.
So it's not overbought.
And inversely.
It's not oversold.
That's the wrong way of defining.
In terms of what's happening.
In words.
It's the wrong way of looking at it.
What's happened when the index level of an
RSI goes above 70, 80, 90 and is really
strong.
It's just confirming your bullish view.
And you could actually miss the trade.
So you have to combine it with other
technicals.
It's a momentum indicator.
Combine it with the technicals of trend
that we've just looked at.
Yeah.
And make up your mind whether it's a good
time to go in or not.
Because short-term momentum just confirms
your view.
And the asset might never ever come down
in price.
But the RSI can.
Just the momentum becomes slower.
But it keeps going up.
Make sense?
What about moving averages?
So we can use exponential moving averages.
If you want to add that in, that's fine.
But we'll look at simple moving average.
SMA.
Just to get the principles covered.
So it just tells you whether momentum is
building in the asset or not.
Or momentum is slowing down.
So if you look at a typical situation
where you're looking at very short-term
moving averages.
Where you've got 10 closing prices of data
over the last 10 days.
6, 5, 6, 7, 9, 8, 8, 10, 13, 16.
The 10-day moving average of those closing
prices is 8.8.
That's a simple average.
The 3-day moving average is 13.
So the last 3 days, 10, 13, 16.
But if you plot a 10-day and a 3-day
moving average.
What would have happened?
On day 6, 7.
The 3-day moving average.
Would have actually cut the 10-day moving
average.
From below.
So when you get those crosses in the
moving averages.
It confirms.
Your view.
If your view is that it's going that way.
But it denies your view.
If you think.
If you think it's going the other way.
Again you're going to have your
fundamental.
Predisposition.
So you can either hang back.
Or participate.
You are the gatekeeper.
Nobody else.
What are the moving averages that we use
in the stock market?
Has anybody ever heard of a golden cross?
Anybody ever heard of that?
When a 50-day moving average crosses a
200-day moving average?
Yeah?
When you go into the market.
You'll hear a lot of people talking about
50-day and 200-day moving averages.
But what is 50 days?
And what is 200 days?
You've got to start reading between the
lines.
Always question what it is.
What does 50 days represent?
How many trading days are there in a
month?
20.
So it's not a quarter is it?
What's 50?
What's 50 days?
Why do people in the market use a 50-day
moving average?
What does 50 days signify?
Huh?
Okay.
So what does 10 weeks represent?
Let's move on to 200.
What does 200 days represent?
These are the most common used moving
averages in the market.
By technical analysis themselves.
Right?
What does 200 days mean?
I don't say four times 50.
Well, don't they use 200 because it's the
number of days where there's no big
structural change in the economy.
Like everything that happens is still
relevant.
Okay.
So why not 199 days?
Because it's a round number.
You just hit the nail on the head because
it's a round number.
It literally doesn't mean anything.
It's a trick question.
50 doesn't mean anything.
200 doesn't mean anything.
So what are the meaningful moving averages
in the stock market?
What are we trading here?
Stocks.
And they're in the stock market.
How many trading days are there in a
month?
20.
So that's one of our important moving
averages.
How many are there in a quarter?
Stocks report quarterly.
GDPs reported quarterly.
We're trading the stock market.
One quarter.
60 days.
How many days in a trading year?
How many trading days in one trading year?
Depending on the year.
250, 251, 252.
So 250 day.
That's one year in the stock market.
And companies report quarterly.
And GDPs reported annually.
50 day means nothing.
200 day means nothing.
So all you'll see is loads of people
talking about the 50 and the 200 day.
They'll all trade for about three hours.
And then they'll all disappear.
So what happens if you've got a
fundamental predisposition of bullish.
And a 20 day moving average crosses a 60
day moving average from above.
As in momentum's down.
Well that just means your one month moving
average has crossed your three month
moving average.
Signifying that in all probability.
For the next quarter.
The price momentum is going to be
negative.
And what happens if a 60 day crosses a 250
day?
So your three month moving average crosses
your one year moving average from above.
And you're bullish.
That's telling you you could be wrong for
the next six to 12 months.
So it might not even be a starter to even
put it on the watch list.
But feel free to put it on the watch list
if you want.
It could take six months for the momentum
to play itself out in the asset.
When you're doing, when you're doing, when
you come across technical analysis in the
market, just sit down, ask the obvious
question.
What is a 50 day moving average?
It just doesn't mean anything.
What is a 200 day moving average?
And overlay that with your own objectives.
What's my objective?
My time horizon is one to three months.
And I trade the stock market.
So if I trade the stock market and there's
20 trading days in a month, 60 and a
quarter, and 250 in a year.
And I'm trading companies that report
quarterly on GDP views that are reported
quarterly and annually.
What are the most important moving
averages to me?
Just ask the obvious question.
So you can add any TA indicator in there
you want.
But that outlines the approach.
Your fundamental predisposition, whether
it agrees, confirms, or denies what you're
thinking.
That's going to stop you doing something
stupid, i.e. buying something at 100,
getting stopped out at 92, then it goes to
400.
Feel free to add anything in.
Don't confuse TA with a tool that
generates the idea for you.
You need to have your view before you pull
up the chart.
A good trade is going to be one that
agrees with your world view, agrees with
your industry view in the stock market,
and your stock view, and technically is
starting to work.
That's when all the boxes are ticked.
That's when all the planets are aligned.
That's when you say, as the gatekeeper,
I'm happy now to allow capital to go into
this situation.
Your idea can be a great idea, but it can
be a badly timed great idea.
So be the gatekeeper to your own capital.
That's the first screening test.
TA.
Okay, welcome back.
So, we just went through, at the
presentation, technical analysis as part
of the gatekeeping process.
Now, when we go through TA, we obviously
are looking at it as one of the most
important timing indicators to good ideas
and also stopping us from putting on bad
ideas.
So, the whole point of this really is to
use TA as a tool to add value to our idea,
as in to turn an idea into a good trade,
because a good idea might not necessarily
be a good trade.
You can end up being stopped out on a good
idea, because you've mistimed it, and then
you'll prove to be right.
We've been through this a few times now.
Probably the most important thing here is
your fundamental predisposition.
So, when you go through the world view,
the industry view, the stock view, and you
arrive at the gatekeeping process, and
your idea is ready to be turned into a
trade, potentially,
you're going to have a fundamental
predisposition, and probably the worst
mistake you can ever make is to then pull
up the chart and then change your mind.
Just forget about it.
You're going to have lots of ideas coming
through your pipeline of ideas,
constantly, because you're going to have
these processes in place, and you'll be
deploying these processes on a weekly
basis.
And if you pull up a chart, and the chart
does not agree with what your fundamental
predisposition is, that doesn't mean it's
a bad idea.
It could be one of the greatest ideas
you've ever had.
You just need to stick it on the watch
list, and you just need to wait to time it
better.
So, please make sure that you do not go
against your fundamental predisposition
when you pull up a chart.
That's just a really, really amateur,
amateur mistake.
So, technical analysis, as part of the
gatekeeping process, just to summarise, is
one of these things that you put up as a
barrier between your ideas and your real
capital before you commit money to a
trade.
You're trying to use it as a tool to
essentially add value to your potentially
good trade, because at the moment, your
idea is just an idea.
Now, we're going to move on to the next
one, which is price action, and we're
going to look at how you develop your
watch list, and the processes that you go
through on a week-to-week basis, in terms
of generating your watch list,
and making sure that your watch list is
up-to-date, and it's serviced correctly,
in terms of providing you with trades, as
in your ideas are on the watch list, and
your watch list then provides you with
trades, alongside your technical analysis.
Okay, let's move on to video number 21,
and I'll see you on the other side.
Thank you.